hello hello hello greetings greetings
greetings
oh my yet another victim of the disease
you are not a doctor you are not a
doctor I sense the disease in you I
sense the disease in you I sense the
disease in you do not be afraid I am the
Cure I found the cure stop resisting I
mean it to cure you stop resisting I
mean to cure you
let's get this strange garment out of
the way I wasn't the way we had company
we rarely get visitors down there I know
you're in here
I know you're in here there's no need to
hide
I'm a Adelle I hear you breathing I hear
you breathing I hear you breathing there
you are there you are I can see you're
not well the sickness has taken hold of
you fear not I'm not trying to arm you
fear not I'm not trying to arm you it
will have less of you life still
it will hurt less if you lie still I can
assure you my cure is most effective my
cure is most effective good heavens it's
worse than I thought like wildfire its
friends they should have brought me here
sooner I need to get to work before the
disease consumes the rest of these poor
souls
I would like to give a special thank you
to Muslim Mookie slump god Justin day
jonno porter captain Gorge fluffy dread
my archive curator neck tie verbal Kody
tench cheese whip depths McGee and
oblong dish boy if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos and some other cool stuff as
well visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
you